I took a trip to Finland and we actually
did a ended up doing a special edition
of late-night showing you know all the
things that I did in Finland and it you
know people seem to really enjoy it it
was kind of a highlight for this show we
had a lot of adventures but there was
actually some footage that we shot in
Finland that didn't quite fit into this
special we were done making a special
and the special was very classy and
highbrow and dignified and then there
was some footage that didn't quite fit
with everything else and so we didn't
include it in the special and we were
we've been looking at it though recently
and we thought it's interesting and
probably should be seen so we thought
we'd show that tonight you see while I
was in Helsinki I visited an art museum
and an unusual art museum and we thought
we'd would show you what happened
tonight check it out
[Music]
you're having an exhibition now on male
underwear as the exhibit been popular
yeah it has been it's a very important
thing for fitness males their underwear
yeah as you can see they have a place
for new Park strollers when you're
taking your toddler to the male
underwear exhibit you explain what's
happening behind you right here this
well this artwork of young finish female
artist
there were her grandparents on the work
that she found from the Attic of the
house and probably not what her
grandparents would have wanted hey when
we're gone and no longer with us go into
the attic find our long unwashed
underwear and put it in a museum well
you never know you say underwear or do
you say Underpants well the fitness of
our this almost host which is like under
pants you know what's funny is to me
underwear isn't funny if someone says
hey there's underwear it's not funny
though what when someone says oh look I
can see your underpants I mean even you
this is laughing for you because this
section is about you know the everyday
life that that is related to on door I
miss you on the back you know nothing
says I miss you like a guy in his long
underwear with his old topper to do in
full time how do you refer to this male
conditionings in Finnish well I mohan
allu you can say it's a nickname for
this thing it's for this thing it's yeah
ha ha no ha no it's good because it
actually sounds like a guy Bob that's
the noises I tend to make yeah when I'm
in this condition this is you
I recognize that risk lobby
looking trust me though when I get
excited I need a pair of these I'm just
gonna keep it all locked down rivets
hang this underwear right here shred it
in the back looks like this guy got it
on with this guy good detective puts the
pieces together this is the work of art
of the photo Herrmann famous artist he
uses watercolors and all of the models
used are famous people I'm told famous
America's this is Tony Shalhoub star
this is from Fear Factor Joe Rogan
exciting
Ed Asner right here this is the you know
the tall guy from everyone loves raymond
very hairy americans were kind enough i
guess is this true to pose for these
yeah I think so
you wouldn't close your eyes and lower
your head when you lie I'm just letting
you know just did that just he just did
it again when you pretended to be amused
by me let's tear this play and see what
else we have
what is your name dr. Pony dr. Pony yes
okay doctor phone I'm good to see you
you say you're a doctor do you have a
doctor's license yes I do
could I see it please oh really you
don't have it with you yeah you just
don't happen to have your certification
yeah but my employer the museum you can
ask them oh sure yeah they're not here
they just left oh yeah yeah yeah kitty
yeah what's in your little pink pouch no
yeah okay and what's in this one well
you don't seem anxious to open house I
think now we know where the roofies are
me but would you what tell me with what
we're looking at here well it's
underwear there's another Kong that's
May that say something hearty err like
beef or chicken or fish this would be
for afterwards I mean you're gonna start
with maybe a salad then maybe a protein
and then then this would be fine I
always say just this song alone seems
irresponsible only one made out of
chewing gum chewing gum yeah those are
fine first those are fine for snacking
but then that sends a bad message let me
try this no I think it would be very
uncomfortable think it would be
uncomfortable and went but then you wear
it and you'll never go to anything else
in our country this underwear was
popularized by Larry King
[Applause]
nothing nothing right take a break when
we come back
Darrell Hammond from Senate live